[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission de la rédaction
consacré à l'actualité sportive du
département tout de suite les titres de
cette émission avec du handball et une
nouvelle défaite pour les joueuses de
montigny le bretonneux la quatrième en
cinquième en cinq matches de championnat
lésigny montée ne sont dernière de
national de l'ong entretien à suivre
dans cette émission avec le skipper
louis burton à 32 ans le navigateur de
rambouillet a pris le départ ce dimanche
de la transat jacques vabre une course
en duo qu'il partage avec sa femme
nous ferons le point sur leurs ambitions
les ambitions elle en a elle aussi
marine tollé disputera samedi prochain à
29 ans son premier combat en
professionnel au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines son portrait à
suivre enfin est démission c'est un
début de saison pour le moins compliquée
pour les joueuses de montigny le
bretonneux elles ont subi ce week-end un
quatrième une quatrième défaite
d'affilée face à chambray en championnat
et ce malgré un bon début de match les
images et le résumé de nicolas landry
quatrième défaite en cinq matches la
mauvaise série se poursuit pour les
handballeuses de montigny le bretonneux
face à chambray 2e du classement et
toujours invaincu lésigny montée non
tenu bon pendant 20 minutes n étaient
alors menés que d'un seul but
on lisait bien les les
les shoots les impacts par rapport à la
gardienne et puis là ça s'est déréglé
ont peut-être par la fatigue peut-être
par le par le stress aussi
mais c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois qu'on
était en échec aux shoots y avait une
contre attaque un but de l'autre côté
quoi six buts d'écart à la mi-temps le
début de la seconde période est plutôt
bien négocié par les joueuses de
montigny plus agressives en défense
elles multiplient quand même les fautes
techniques
score final 25 37 et une deuxième
défaite à domicile cette saison dernière
du classement avec seulement 6 points
lésigny montée ne reste soudé pas de
crise à l'ordre du jour on reste motivés
parce que l'année dernière on a vécu un
peu le même scénario ont perdu tous nos
matches au début et on a tous remontés à
la fin est comme la poule aller assez
serré bas on garde espoir
les filles sont vraiment soudée il y
aurait une crise si on se
on se disputait sur le terrain ou dans
les vestiaires ce qui n'est pas le cas
j'ai un groupe extraordinaire qui a
besoin de travailler prochain match pour
la s montigny samedi prochain avec un
déplacement à saint maur un club aussi
mal classés avec une seule victoire en
championnat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en bref d'autres résultats sportifs du
week-end passé avec la victoire de
plaisir handball les plaisirs oies se
sont largement imposés face à saint-maur
en nationale 3 score final 29 20
l'équipe est 3e de son classement et
affrontera les derniers de leur
championnat le week end prochain
défaite en revanche pour les
basketteuses du chéné c'était samedi
soir à domicile elles ont perdu leur
troisième match en championnat face aux
nordistes d'armentières
prochain match pour les chaînes et
viennent toujours à domicile ce sera
samedi à 20 heures face au deuxième du
classement
ils ont pris hier la direction du brésil
depuis le port du havre 2 yvelinois sont
parmi les 74 aux skippers en lice dans
la transat jacques vabre la course de
voile transatlantique en duo le
versaillais tanguy de la mode fait
équipe avec la britannique samantha
davies une nouvelle fois pour initiative
coeur leur participation permettra de
récolter des fonds pour sauver un
maximum d'enfants malades du coeur les
deux skippers font la course sur un
bateau baptisé par le spationaute thomas
pesquet enfin deuxième coureur du
département en lice originaire de
rambouillet louis burton est engagé lui
avec sa femme
servane escoffier pour bureau vallée
également en catégorie imoca et le
couple est ambitieux pour cette course
comme a pu le constater notre
journaliste sportif miquel et demi
d'euros il a rencontré louis burton
quelques jours avant le départ de la
course était à paris regardez je suis
avec louis burton le rambolitains alors
louis vous allez prendre le départ de la
transat jacques vabre dans quelques
jours comment vous sentez-vous tout
simplement plus tôt plutôt stressé là
pour le moment
c'est vrai qu on est à quelques jours
d'une grosse échéance pour nous c'est la
jacques vabre qui a lieu tous les deux
ans qui une course importante c'est la
plus longue et transats ont par duras
vrai on va au brésil et on a un nouveau
bateau cette année bureau vallée 2
qui est une machine qui tendent ans qui
vient de gagner le vendée globe donc un
peu d'appréhension de savoir comment ça
se passe évidemment
justement comment il est ce bateau alors
vous avez pu le tester
on l'a testé évidemment on s'est
entraîné avec depuis le mois d'avril
donc il fait les mêmes dimensions que le
premier puisque c'était un classe imoca
mais il fait 2 tonnes de moins pour les
mêmes dimensions il a des foils donc
c'est comme des ailes d'avion mais qui
sont sous l'eau qui soulage le bateau
qui le font accélérer il a un marotta
tiff il n'est pas du tout équipés de la
même manière donc voilà on rentre dans
une nouvelle dans une nouvelle ère du
projet est évidemment ça demande pas mal
de temps et de concentration il va plus
vite si je comprends bien il va beaucoup
beaucoup plus vite
ouais il est arrivé il est arrivé quinze
jours avant moi ou vendée globe par
exemple sur 90 jours
c'est un bateau qui
va très vite avec beaucoup moins de vent
qui va plus vite en vitesse moyenne du
fait qu'il sorte de l'eau et qui vole en
quelque sorte et
voilà il est pressé par ailleurs
beaucoup plus physique puisque c'est un
bateau qui monte sur ces fameux fun mais
qui est quand même une qui donc il
redescend régulièrement dans les vagues
donc ça tape beaucoup plus c'est plus
éprouvant nerveusement ça fait plus de
bruit
voilà bon l'avantagé que ça va beaucoup
plus vite et vous allez réaliser ce
parcours en duo avec votre femme servane
pourquoi avoir choisi servane pour
partir sur cette transat jacques vabre
alors il ya une raison qui est il ya
plusieurs raisons mais il ya une raison
qui est historique
servane et est une des championnes
françaises les plus titrés en course au
large
quand je les rencontre et en 2010 je lui
avais proposé de faire la jacques vabre
et l'idée était de bénéficier de son
expérience et puis son sa vision
féminine de la course et de
l'utilisation de ces machines
voilà ça s'est pas fait en 2011 ni en
2013 et en 2015 les quelques années pour
que ça se mette en place voilà il
fallait quelques années et puis là en
fait
partir avec elle sur ce nouveau bateau
m'a semblé très intéressant puisqu'on
découvre le support ensemble c'est un
bateau qui très fragile qu'à une zone
rouge plus grande et plus proches
l'ancien et donc avoir une présence
féminine d'abord ça va permettre d'avoir
de philosophie et de façon de naviguer
différentes
elle va probablement être un peu plus
dans l'anticipation et dans la prudence
est donc
donc peut-être
moi mais équilibré dans mon côté
fougueux et mon envie d'être d'être
devant avec ce bateau là donc je le
rappelle servane c'est votre femme
qu'est ce que ça va changer concrètement
sur le bateau ça va être plus compliqué
plus facile peut-être alors il ya il ya
évidemment des écueils dans lesquels il
faut pas tomber on est on
un couple à terre mais c'est vrai que
quand on va là partir en mer ce sont des
courses qui sont quand même extrêmement
dur donc il faut pas faire de
sensibilité
poussez faut vraiment se dire qu'on a un
équipage donc c'est le deal qu'on a fait
et puis ensuite le côté sympa c'est
comme on se connaît très bien on va être
on est on est plus libre de s'exprimer
sur notre façon de voir les choses nos
façons de voir la course les options la
stratégie la météo on n'a pas ce frein
qu'on peut avoir quand on pas quelqu'un
qu'on connaît pas ou peu c'est un
avantage c'est un avantage c'est une
certitude sinon je ne l'aurais pas je le
ferai pas et ça devrait nous permettre
j'espère
[Musique]
faire les bons choix et peut-être de
prendre des meilleures décisions que les
autres
cruciaux vous avez participé au vendée
globe la dernière édition du vendée
globe
là où participer à la transat jacques
vabre quelle est la différence on le
vendée globe c'est une course en
solitaire un tour du monde là c'est
beaucoup plus rapide
alors le whale la première grosse
différence c'est que le vendée globe se
court en solitaire l'aca secours à deux
donc c'est quand même pas du tout la
même approche
la deuxième grosse différence c'est que
le vendée c'est le tour de la planète ça
dure presque trois mois là c'est une
course avec ces bateaux là qui va durer
une quinzaine de jours donc on est
plutôt dans un format de sprint en plus
comme on est à 2 tout le monde est à 2
sur cette jacques vabre le
les bateaux sont menées à 100% de leur
potentiel il n'ya pas les temps morts
qu'on peut avoir ou les phases un petit
peu plus creuse qu'on peut avoir quand
on est en solitaire c'est un sprint
finalement donc c'est ça c'est une
baisse la tête on a la tête dans le
guidon et puis et puis on fort
pendant quinze jours au niveau de vos
objectifs
quels sont vos objectifs le podium si je
comprends bien on rêve de ça c'est vrai
que sur les sur les trois dernières
jacques vabre que auquel j'ai participé
avec leurs valets
meilleure place à était cinquième donc
il faut absolument là on a un bateau
génial j'aime gagner le vendée qu'il ya
un bateau de toute dernière génération
il faut absolument qu'on fasse mieux que
5e c'est sûr et puis et puis le podium
je pense que c'est à notre portée même
si c'est vrai il ya une concurrence
vraiment élevé sur cette jacques vabre
avec des très bons bateaux mais aussi
des dégâts qui navigue avec leur bateau
qu'on fait le vendée globe qui navigue
depuis longtemps avec leurs bateaux donc
va falloir s'accrocher et puis et
envoyer du lourd dans la question qu'est
ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter louis
burton et bas à vous et à votre
coéquipière ça va devoir des caïpirinhas
à salvador de bahia en fêtant un podium
on roule c est en tout cas merci louis
burton est un peu plus de 24 heures
après leur départ les deux yvelinois
sont bien placés dans leur catégorie
imoca tanguy de lamotte et 6e louis
burton 7e à seulement dix milles marins
de la tête de course
il y avait du cyclisme ce week-end au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines avec la quatrième édition du
grand prix de vélizy près de 140
concurrents ont participé au rendez vous
dimanche dont des jeunes pousses du
cyclisme sur piste français mille
spectateurs étaient également présents
dans les tribunes reportage de nicolas
landry du spectacle sur la piste du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
pour cette quatrième édition du grand
prix de vélizy frédéric est venu avec
son frère et son fils pour regarder les
champions c'est la première fois que je
venais au vélodrome où j'ai souvent eu
l'occasion
souvent envie de venir mais jamais eu
l'occasion de venir le vélodrome c'est
quelque chose de sympathique de nouveau
pour moi
et
et c'est vrai que c'est impressionnant
voix s'étrangle on se demande comment on
peut tenir dessus pour tenir sur la
rampe les pistards se prépare à l'effort
c'est le cas de guillaume sous terre
engagés sur la course par élimination
le principe tous les deux tours le
cycliste arrivé en dernier est éliminé
une épreuve remportée par guillaume je
suis content est-ce que toujours plaisir
de gagner surtout qu'il ya quand même du
niveau et je me suis bien fait mal aux
pattes scratch vitesse par équipes tempo
différentes disciplines du cyclisme sur
piste de la catégorie shon à seniors
masculines et féminines venant de
différentes régions
c'est un révélateur de jeunes talents
faut pas oublier que à la première
édition nous avions laurie berton
quentin lafargue nous avions benjamin
thomas morgan kneisky qui sont tous en
équipe de france et qui sont devenus
champions du monde lui est déjà champion
du monde catégorie junior vitesse
individuelle à 18 ans rien n'est là l'a
rejoint le pôle france
il a participé à l'épreuve de keirin
huit tours dont 6 effectué derrière la
moto avant un sprint final remporté par
le jeune espoir
le pistard de vélizy anne dujarier est
arrivé troisième de l1
attentive à ce qui se passait derrière
j'ai tout de suite vu que barack
deriassa voulait pas trop prendre la
tête je suis pas je reste en tête et
j'étais vigilants derrière super content
j'avais j'ai tiré le bon le bon numéro
jus dans la roue du jeu plus du monde
j'ai juste essayé de conserver sa roue
je suis resté dedans et avec le break et
que j'avais une miss j'ai réussi même à
pouvoir accélérer sur la dernière ligne
droite
deuxième manche de cette compétition au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le dimanche 26 novembre du cyclisme
toujours dans ce set 8 sport avec un
coup de projecteur aujourd'hui sur
françois pervis le pistard de l'équipe
de france sept fois champion du monde
ces dernières semaines le sportif a
décidé de faire l'impasse sur des
épreuves de coupe du monde ou sur les
championnats d'europe fin octobre
objectif revenir plus fort pour la
prochaine coupe du monde
ambition et explications au micro de
notre journaliste sportif michael et
demi d'euros qui a pu le rencontrer au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à mes côtés
françois pervis qui n'a pas participé
aux derniers championnats d'europe de
cyclisme sur piste qui est resté ici au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines pour s'entraîner françois c'est
ça oui c'est ça j'ai décidé de pas
participer aux europe parce que je
préférais penser à ma programmation pour
les championnats du monde et les
championnats d'europe pour moi ça
tombait vraiment mal cette année
je suis vraiment déçu de pas les avoir
faits mais en même temps je préfère être
champion du monde et champion d'europe
donc j'ai préféré mettre toutes les
chances de mon côté pour les
championnats du monde c'est un choix que
l'équipe de france a compris le
l'encadrement de l'équipe de france a
compris oui oui mes entraîneurs
voulaient que je fasse s'échapper à
d'europe mais finalement je leur ai mis
en avant mais
c'est pourquoi je ne voulais pas les
faire et ben on s'est mis d'accord et
puis on a optimisé pour l'entraînement
et du coup cet entraînement en quoi ça
consiste
non seulement c'est très très dur c'est
beaucoup de beaucoup de foncier en fait
cette année pour la première fois de ma
carrière depuis 15 ans j'ai coupé deux
mois après les championnats du monde en
avril dernier
donc deux mois c'est beaucoup parce que
des petites choses que quinze jours donc
a fallu refaire les bases les fondations
et donc ça prend du temps c'est du
travail de fourmi un petit peu chaque
jour et donc il me fallait une des
grandes périodes d'entraînement
donc en ce moment j'enchaîne les cycles
de cinq semaines entrecoupées d'une
semaine très très light donc c'est pour
ça que tout ce qui était juillet août
septembre octobre faisait ça faisait
partie de cette période d'entraînement
intensif donc pour ça les championnats
d'europe au mois d'octobre
c'était un peu trop tôt pour moi vous
avez besoin de cette coupure de deux
mois oui vous ressourcer après tous ces
titres que vous avez gagné dans le passé
ah c'est vrai que depuis 2013 je cours
je cours partout j'ai gagné pas mal de
choses
je me suis un petit peu oubliée
personnellement donc le réservoir est
diminuée diminue diminué c'est important
de pouvoir se ressourcer de penser un
petit peu un soir est assez vrai que ces
quatre dernières années
ça a été
200% à tout le temps comme j'ai dit tout
à leur maximum j'ai coupé une fois
quinze jours par an donc en quinze jours
on a à peine le temps de se poser que le
corps aussi récupère le l'esprit
l'esprit et le corps récupère donc très
important de faire cette grosse coupure
et aujourd'hui je ne regrette pas parce
que finalement j'ai très bien pris
justement vous allez être peut-être plus
fort peut-être sur les prochaines
compétitions
bah c'est cette vite c'est le but la
récupération fait partie de la
progression
donc mon corps voilà j'ai 33 ans je vis
33 ans récemment ça fait ça fait 17 ans
que en équipe de france donc il faut
savoir
posez des vacances se poser pour ne pas
se faire saturer le corps et l'esprit
donc là je pense que jusqu'au bout
tourne en ce moment ça devrait ça sent
bon pour la suite du coup il ya ces
championnats du monde qui vont arriver
aux pays bas fin février début mars
comment vous les appréhender ces
championnats du monde en sachant que
vous avez quatre titres sur le kilomètre
vous en voulez un cinquième c'est ça oui
je reviens 5e parce que hein mais pas
rassasiée non je suis pas rassasié j'ai
pas tout gagner j'ai pas tout gagner et
là mon objectif c'est vraiment de gagner
ce cinquième titre de champion du monde
si je gagne ce cinquième titre de
champion du monde je serai le premier de
toute l'histoire de mon sport à être
cinq fois champion du monde soit km donc
pour l'instant on est cinq ex-aequo à
avoir quatre titres donc j'ai encore une
chance moi de pouvoir pouvoir faire
mieux que les aînés et de passer devant
et d'être d'être seul donc pour moi
c'est important j'ai envie de marquer
l'histoire de mon sport et encore on est
sprinter sur piste on est là pour battre
des records et ça c'est un record vous
centrée uniquement sur le km uh
vous envisagez des victoires sur le
keirin qui est votre spécialité
également oui non non le kilomètre y a
pas que ça j'ai vraiment envie d'être de
redevenir champion du monde d'acquérir
les aux derniers championnats du monde
je me suis fait déclasser un peu un peu
durement en demi finale donc j'ai pas pu
aller en finale et peut-être que moi je
pense que j'avais une belle médaille
voire le titre qui ne tiennent pas sur
le nez donc là je suis très heureux
revanchard j'y pense tous les jours
donc vous n'avez pas laisser échapper à
la médaille c'est ça non non non la jedi
nom et le titre peut-être encore moi
j'ai vraiment envie de redevenir
champion du monde de curling et puis
aussi la vitesse par équipes
on est en pleine restructuration avec
des bons jeunes et baffe au futur faire
sa place donc c'est important en vue des
jeux olympiques de tokyo 2011 justement
cette jeune ils poussent ils ont
remporté huit médailles dont cinq en or
aux derniers championnats d'europe qui
se sont déroulés à berlin est ce que ça
vous met plus de pression ou est-ce que
ça vous motive encore plus les dépasser
les 2 forcément qu'on est quand on a mon
âge et qu'on voit des jeunes arriver
qu'on le voit progresser
ben on fait en sorte qu'ils nous passent
pas de vin parce qu'on a envie de
continuer à nous à moi en tant qu'ancien
a gagné un métier de champion du monde
et à garder ma place donc c'est bien
qu'ils aient déjà déjà pour l'équipe de
france
mais en plus de ça moi ça permet aussi
de 2,2
de me dépasser encore plus à
l'entraînement et surtout ne pas dormir
sur mes lauriers ça c'est très important
vous avez 33 ans est ce qu'il vous reste
encore de nombreuses années dans le
cyclisme sur piste
on va dire que je pense que je me mets
pas de barrière je m'en suis assez mise
comme ça pendant pendant une dizaine
d'années à partir de manger et fait
sauter c'est là où j'ai commencé à
gagner donc en maintenant des barrières
je m'en vais plus mais honnêtement sans
mentir je pense que tokyo 2020 ce sera
s'approchera de la fin j'aurais 36 ans
on a déjà vu des champions olympiques à
36 ans comme chris hoy l'anglais donc
moi je me dis pourquoi pas aujourd'hui
voilà j'ai encore un mode champion du
monde sur le dos donc c'est que je pense
pouvoir toujours été à la hauteur donc
trois ans ça va vite arriver mine de
rien les jeux olympiques c'était il ya
déjà plus d'un an
les derniers donc ça passe très vite le
temps passe très vite et comme je le dis
je suis très motivé comme un cadet et je
fais toujours très très attention
vraiment à tous à être à cent pour cent
sûr surtout surtout les à-côtés va se
coller sportif de haut niveau il ya les
heures entraîné donc ici au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
mais les urnes ont entraîné ce que je
fais à côté quand je suis chez moi ce
que je mange comme on mange dort à ne
pas rester sur mes jambes ne pas faire
n'importe quoi donc c'est très important
d'avoir une vie saine voilà c'est bien
voilà avoir une vie saine et puis
on va tout faire pour protéger
le plus professionnel possible de 1024
c'est trop loin pour vous j'aurai 40 ans
là c'est sûr ce sera trop loin à mon
grand regret parce que voilà ce sera ici
les jeux olympiques donc à une décision
près peut-être qu'on aurait pu avoir ici
en 2020 soit vraiment été l'apothéose
si je les avais fait ici et encore plus
si
si j'ai une médaille mais pour moi le
tokyo japon c'est ça compte
j'ai passé six années au japon s'est ces
dernières années donc
le japon c'est comme on va dire ma
deuxième maison je passe beaucoup de
temps là bas c'est vraiment japon qui
m'a permis de progresser de passer de
toujours le poulidor parce que pendant
six ans j'ai toujours fait 2e au
championnat du monde au pouvoir qui a
gagné les deux champions du monde donc
le japon a vraiment révélées et donc si
je pouvais finir ma carrière là bas sur
une médaille olympique ce serait
vraiment très beau conte ou le souhaite
françois pervis et on vous souhaite
également de réaliser de belles
performances aux prochains championnats
du monde qui se dérouleront en février
et en mars aux pays bas c'est le rendez
vous sportifs du week-end prochain
samedi he 11 novembre un grand gala de
boxe sera organisé au vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines 12 combats
sont programmés parmi eux celui de
marine tollé de la team farruggia
d'elancourt la boxeuse disputera pour
l'occasion son tout premier match de
boxe en professionnel à l'âge de 29 ans
son portrait toujours par michael et
demi d'euros
ce mercredi 1er novembre ne déroge pas à
la règle comme tous les jours marine
taulé 29 ans vient avec le sourire pour
sa session de boxe quotidienne dans
cette salle d'elancourt
une passion que la boxeuse originaire de
jouars-pontchartrain pratique depuis
l'âge de 7 ans voulaient plus beaucoup
plus jeunes fermé foot
sauf qu'à l'époque le foot féminin
n'était pas aussi réputés que maintenant
et mes parents ne voulaient pas et ils
sont 10 quitte à faire un sport de
garçons autant aux tentes un quelque
chose qui va te servir qui va te permet
de défendre propre a pas de faire de la
boxe à 21 ans lives in ways décide de
passer un palier de rejoindre la team
farrugia une des meilleures équipes de
france qui compte notamment dans ses
rangs le champion d'europe marvin petit
et surtout temps guy farrugia un
entraîneur réputé dans le monde de la
boxe
je n'ai pas grillé les bras ouverts je
suis quelques problèmes avec les filles
qui a eu avant dont on a comme on
appelle ça on a gelé pas accueilli je
lui dis bien va taper dans le sens que
tu veux mais je m'en occuperai pas de
toi et elle a réussi à s'intégrer à
pousser les murs
et la partie latine tels que moi mais
bon elle avait réussi à se donner à fond
tout simplement un départ pour un duo
qui fonctionne encadrés par tanguy
farrugia marine remporté dix victoires
en douze combats de boxe amateur des
résultats qui l'ont poussé à s'inscrire
chez les professionnels premier combat
ce samedi 11 9 ans au vélotour national
de saint quentin en yvelines dans la
catégorie moins de 57 kg la boxeuse
affrontera la niçoise nahid kharchi
championne du monde pieds poings
l'objectif c'est de remporter le combat
trouve tous les boxeurs ont pour
objectif d'initier un ring c'est de
gagner le combat
après avant la limite
dans les temps au point peu importe
l'idée c'est d'y aller à 100% de 150%
même de ses capacités d'y aller à fond
on ne peut pas y aller à moitié cette
dernière mise de gants de s'y rendent au
palais des sports dit long cours a
laissé entrevoir de belles promesses
mais le contexte sera différent dans
quelques jours devant des milliers de
spectateurs au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines
on change complètement d'univers et
direction à présent du parc le parc du
château de plaisir où était organisé il
ya quelques jours le trente deuxième
grand prix de la ville par le club local
de l'amicale des boules plaisir oise le
rendez vous a réuni plus de 350
doublettes masculines et féminines des
duos pointer tireurs venus
principalement dit de france on écoute à
ce propos le secrétaire du club
christophe dédiant c'est l'événement
majeur pour la ville de plaisir et
notamment pour le club de la baie
plaisir puisque c'est le plus gros
concours de france sur une journée oui
il ya beaucoup de pression parce que une
fois que vous avez perdu
c'est terminé pour gagner l'après midi
pour un autre concours mais oui il ya
beaucoup de pression parce que c'est un
concours qui écrit tricoter sur l'île de
france
c'était la semaine passée aussi les
vacances de la toussaint ont permis aux
jeunes hockeyeurs des chocs ce
d'elancourt de se perfectionner une
quinzaine d'entre eux ont participé
toute la semaine dernière à un stage
intensif au programme renforcement
musculaire pour ces jeunes hommes et
répétition des gammes aussi comme nous
l'expliquent le président du club dans
le cadre du stage comme ils sont là
partir de 9h30 ce matin jusqu'à 90 le
soir ça leur permet d'être vraiment
totalement d'environnement ok sur la
totalité du du stage de la semaine et de
pratiquer vraiment de de faire des
exercices
y compris des exercices basique de type
passe des types sortie drôle eux
sur des sur des longues durées et de
vraiment prendre le temps de les
maîtriser les estomacs des enfants s'en
rappellent encore halloween permet pour
les plus gourmands de manger des bonbons
sans remords particulier pour les plus
sportifs c'est l'occasion aussi de faire
du sport ainsi aux clayes-sous-bois la
ville organisé son premier trail
halloween 400 sorcières et vampires
avait rendez-vous pour l'occasion
reportage de miquel et les minéraux
sorcière chauve-souris mort-vivante
antilles ce mercredi 1er novembre la
ville des clayes-sous-bois pour
participer à ce premier tri l'oin une
course à pied au départ du parc jean
carillo imaginé par les organisateurs
depuis le mois de janvier dernier sur
cette date il y avait peu de courses
dans la région donc là comme yavé rien
je me suis dit mais pourquoi pas me
glisser sur 7 sur cette date du 1er
novembre et ensuite le trail il déduit
trahi le wind pour faire un petit clin
d'oeil à halloween
les deux sources à cette course
terrifiante proposé de la marche
nordique et des courses de 10 et 18 km à
travers les bois
un programme qui a séduit plus de 450
âmes perdues sur cette première édition
on en fait pas l'aumône hier soir ça
nous empêche pas de fêter et puis on
vient on vient sans aucune appréhension
à faire 18 tranquillement sort pas de
problème perry d'e.on et non mais et
thématique c'est un non franchement
c'est très très bonne idée on est hyper
content d'être là malgré la horde de
monstres qui l'entouraient pendant la
course christophe deprez a eu le coeur
solidement accroché pour remporter le 10
km en 39 minutes et 30 secondes
c'est vrai il faut gérer entre les côtes
le plat donc je suis plus qu'un de nos
routes donc le plat malien les côtes
un peu plus dur mais bon à d'autres
académies finir une fois l'apocalypse de
la course passé la matinée c'est
évidemment terminée par une dégustation
d'une potion à base de potiron
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
deuxième édition de ce trait lwin
cauchemardesque
[Musique]
tu es la fin de ce sept huit sports
retour de l'information en direct demain
à 18h sur l'antenne de tv 78 bonne
semaine à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]